John réveille ce que j'ai entendu
crier juste à côté reste ici mais vérifie que
tout va bien
ils sont couverts de sang retourne à l'intérieur
j'ai vu mon fils retourner à l'intérieur appeler les
incas tout de suite aller j'aime ton chien
tu as survécu tu n'  t sortir de l'
autre côté de quelque chose comme ça plus faible
qu'est-ce qu'il reste à avoir peur c'est
le dernier d'entre eux comment est-ce arrivé
là-dedans je jure qu'il l'a jeté ça a
dû se mélanger là-bas elle s'intègre bien
il y a des choses  se passe qu'il peut
expliquer que nous devrions parler à quelqu'un je
ne pense pas que vous vivez en tant
que fantôme
parfois les démons peuvent s'attacher
à des objets
protéger votre famille
vous êtes vous
Tamia sarcomes d'accord j'aime posi à la maison
leur tapis